mainly because we forgot that our
forefathers created this country as the
land of opportunity even if it's Shady
opportunity
[Music]
all right so you guys remember during
obviously the pandemic everything went
really really crazy in different ways
one of the things that came about it was
something known as the eviction
um moratorium you guys remember what
that is they couldn't kick you out they
couldn't kick you out right uh well
here's the thing the particular City uh
Berkeley their City's eviction
moratorium has just been lifted
and you talk about the University
Berkeley Berkeley area
yeah Berkeley okay yeah so
the Berkeley Property Owners Association
they actually the a bunch of landlords
basically got together and celebrated
this in a public place oh [__] like we
could kick our people oh which led to
protests and rights and people coming
out and then eventually eventually a lot
of fist fights and [__] like that ended
up having people got attacked and stuff
like that bro this is wild they got
vintage vintage Jiu Jitsu yeah I get
their sentiment but the way they went
about it is kind of [__] up but like
if you that is weird if you do have a
home and you're relying on that rental
income and for like 12 months or
whatever you're getting paid nothing and
you still have to pay a mortgage and
property tax people lose their house to
the bank like that when the renters
don't they can get foreclosed forever so
I that's dope that yay the incomes come
in but then like like
out and we have a party in a public
place yeah it's a public place yeah it's
a little extra well there are people
that have like their homes being
squatted in for years and no one's
paying rent they're just like sick of it
they don't they feel like they can't do
anything about it and then it's probably
like a big celebration too we get to
kick out this [__] senior citizen
well I guess it comes down to just like
the uh just the way right because like
on both sides it's like it either sucks
or it's understood or whatever right but
yeah like if you're gonna throw a
cocktail party maybe maybe do it in one
of the homes you own you know what I
mean maybe do it in like a very
undisclosed private place versus in a
place that like as much as you're right
it does seem like there's a [__] up
part about it celebrate after you kick
them out and then use that house to
celebrate in
yeah don't celebrate don't celebrate
while the person's still in the house
yeah wait and then but yes invite them
after I mean how do you protect how do
you make laws to where you protect
people that are like having a hard time
and then how do you protect
from the scam artists that use those
laws to exploit people that are
homeowners so it's like
I don't know man catch 22. yeah because
then it's like the law was put in place
because it's like a lot of people lost
their jobs and then they're like oh [__]
well I still need a place to live
but I don't know like maybe later I'll
pay you know when I get a job that's
reasonable right but there's also crews
out there that are like
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
move into this nice new mansion and then
we're gonna move in our neighbors and
family and we're gonna house party every
night and never pay rent
it was like how do you find a battle I
think the part that's [__] up is like
it's like three parties you have like uh
like the politician and then you have
like the halves and the have-nots and
then the politicians are kind of going
like wait you got strong legs hey sit on
your shoulders
and then so that's the kind of like
that's the relationship while the
politicians can just flip that scenario
whenever they want versus it's I feel
like if I was a person holding the
person's legs I'm like well if you want
to help people so that let's take turns
you he said on your shoulders too but
then it's not it's never that way so you
just kind of make the people just fight
each other
and then so that now those guys are like
at each other's um
like throats when that shouldn't even be
the relationship because it's the
politicians making the rules
that pit people against each other
you guys know what I'm saying yeah
that's that's politics baby I know
that's what [__] sucks like for
example like at our gym right like gyms
are one of the hardest ones to get hit
with the pandemic we got shut down twice
as soon as we got shut down
um we're like oh [__] like a lot of our
staff are young they're like 19 20 20 21
but like they rely on this income so
um me Gio and one of our other like
Senior Management members were like
let's cut our income in half and we'll
just pay them we'll pretend like they're
still on shift and we just pay them
hourly wages as if they're working 20
hours a week because at this time we
didn't know about unemployment or
anything like that we just knew these
guys live in the surrounding areas no
one has jobs let's just pay
and that's something that we were
willing to take on
and without the politicians like
involvement so that actually felt very
honest and it felt good versus if the
politicians were to just come in you pay
him and then you do this to him then now
that they reverse the situation now all
of a sudden there's like this weird
animosity and it's like it feels weird
yeah that's amazing what'd you do for
your employees a lot of them don't work
with us anymore so I don't know if it
was awesome
yo y'all hiring yeah sure yeah even
during that time too right like people
were applying for like business PPP
loans that were forgiven and stuff like
that and whatnot and it's like us like
with our business structure The Way We
Were what we were applying for we could
only get so much help based off like
taxes that we had paid in previous years
and the way that was written down
and then other people are creating
[__] fake llc's and pulling in hella
money you know you know how much money
they lost from PPP scams billions oh
there's people that took so much of that
and like
they're not being caught like no one's
getting in trouble for it there's people
in jail that even filed for unemployment
and they're getting like the 3 600 uh
[__] a week check too yeah there's
definitely a lot of people who who are
getting away with it but some people are
getting
getting slapped on the wrist during that
time what kind of [__] up the economy
was like so you gave a bunch of
companies forgiveness loans or a ton of
money to loans so they can survive the
pandemic right but at the same time you
gave a ton of
just people in general like money so a
lot of their employees that left they
didn't want to come back because they
were getting more money from
um by not working by not working yeah so
they didn't the government didn't
actually just match their paycheck they
gave them a ton of money so you were
making like 3K a week or whatever doing
nothing
and then you're like well if I start
working I'm gonna lose this yeah so why
should I work that's [__] up so that
there was a lot of yeah I think it was
just like faulty system they they acted
too fast
and it's like I I don't know like it was
good that people got paid but at what
cost like we're dealing with that now
yeah damn I had to work
you should have got PVP I mean no you
should have got the unemployment yeah
the part that sucks is when you look
back at it you're like the people that
bent the rules
benefited the most and the people that
try to play it the correct way kind of
got the [__] into the stick yeah the
people that kept their jobs they
actually
for following the rules they actually
didn't make as much yeah because one of
our other friends who's a YouTuber
in his LLC he has one employee which is
him right because he owns his channel
he fired himself
and claimed EDD that 3 600 uh a month or
whatever and uh so he was able to
collect that by him firing himself but
technically the YouTube money is still
in his pocket and when he told me about
that I was like he's like you should do
it too I was like dude that's [__]
genius but it sounds [__] [__] up
it's not scary and then looking back I
was like you calculate that times that
by 12 or like oh [__] I think that was
like [__] 70 G's or something crazy
number like should I have done that you
know it's crazy I know we like played by
the rules yeah we didn't exploit
anything and I'm like how come all these
people are winning doing that I wish I
did that but I didn't I had another
friend he got the PPP loan he has like a
eight-figure company so their loans are
huge because they match your last three
years of income
he got the PVP loan I think he got like
maybe 8 million or something
he used that money to buy a warehouse
under a different company and then now
he uh rents it to his current company so
he used that to buy commercial space so
there's just people that are like they
see the opportunity and when I like look
at things I'm like it just doesn't feel
right yeah and then I'm like but then
because I don't I don't feel right now
I'm not balling like this guy
we don't feel right both ways yeah the
opportunity comes it doesn't feel right
and then you see your friends get the
opportunity and it doesn't feel right
seeing them [__] win
I feel like California you just bend it
at this point bend it because they don't
really care yeah California it's
California you know I mean they don't
even care about criminals as much so
[__] it that's what it seems like dude
just bend no one cares they don't care I
said maybe that's because we forgot that
our forefathers created this country as
the land of opportunity even if it's
Shady opportunity
I mean she wrote that in there put in
parentheses Shady and then just in God
we trust you know what I mean it's not
even like people that run this [__] we
should run some scams
I knew some people that they were trying
to apply for the unemployment
but somebody claimed it for them and
you're like what so they got checks to
somebody else through their own name and
they're like it's going to a completely
different address like I don't know who
this [__] person because they have
the same name I don't know I just no
social security probably got jacked yeah
it was unlucky bro just got got so a lot
of and he this is a person that needed
it he was like a massage therapist
during the pandemic yeah and he actually
needed it yeah bro and he looked and he
was he's like who's gonna massage me
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you